welcome back the prez who's never alert
is officially older than dirt
yeah Joe's feeling fine as he parties
like he's no longer 79.
President Joe Biden celebrated his 80th
birthday yesterday in typical typical
fashion wondering where the hell he is
it marks the first time ever that an
American president has turned 80 in the
Oval Office and the first time the Oval
Office desk chair doubled as a toilet
he celebrated with his family in the
white house with his favorite a coconut
cake
did someone warn him coconuts are a
natural laxative
puts a smile on his face though and one
on the teeth floating in the glass on
his nightstand
cheap Biden and his handlers have said
he's fit for the job and more than
capable of running for re-election
despite his Advanced age and that when
he shakes hands with imaginary people he
has the grip strength of a teenager
Joe himself has said he felt 50 which
raises the question 50 what
just wondering there's a women's college
nearby so it could be anything
as we celebrate the commander-in-chief
let's take a long trip down memory lane
or at least a confused Meander through
the Rose Garden
2 10 12 15. hope stepping on them
there's a it's black Anyway by the way
it's my little sister Valerie and I'm
Jill's husband
um
uh
I can't hard trouble reading this then
the percentage of the men who do so end
of quote repeat the line
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
oh
unlike the president that never gets old
now let's go to the birthday boy himself
how are you celebrating your birthday
no no no look look I'm 80 years old but
uh Happy Birthday to me happy birthday
to me I feel 50. feel 50. that's how you
get the Joe age you subtract 30. text
Joe to minus 3-0
and I I remember 30 years ago when I was
50 I felt 20.
I remember what I was doing just like
you I was listening to some good head
banging music
yeah
so uh Walter not a day goes by when
people tell me that you uh that Biden
reminds them of you would say you we
have gotten that since uh since Obama
yeah yeah I look just like and so you
know our Specialists coming up on Friday
I actually played Biden in the special
right but you're not actually him no not
actually him but you know uh I need six
perfectly because someone else is always
telling me what to say
laughs
and you can put me in office and at
least you'd know for sure I'm not the
one running the show
what uh where can they see the special
uh it's going to be on Comedy Central
Comedy Central which is part of the
terror now which is a great thing except
we are on CBS This Morning and now we
come here and now it's a I feel a little
dirty both ways
yeah so uh so yeah so we had fun with it
and by the way watching those films it's
just no matter what side you're on how
could you how could you take that
seriously yeah and you know we all have
friends on the other side of the country
some of us do some of us don't and yeah
you know asking a guy the other day how
are we viewed right now and it's what
you hear it's just like we reviewed as
kind of a joke and it's kind of sad but
it gives you material so I love it yeah
there you go
let's say you cat you know the thing is
are we being a little too ageist I'm
beginning to think that Biden's age is
not the worst thing about him no it's
improv it's impressive like I don't
think I'll see 80. no I no I'm serious I
think I think I'm gonna get like a
really Insidious rare cancer in my early
50s oh come on don't bring everybody
down no but then I'll but then I'll beat
it oh okay but then it'll come back with
a vengeance and I'll die before 60.
hahaha but it's not his age because I
like I know a few 80 year olds you know
not to brag but like
they don't act like that no they don't
they like they don't act like he's like
well I'll just you know he's like well
you just have to judge if I'm keeping up
the same Pace because I'm like I'm
concerned about the pace you're at now
every time he gets out a full sentence
I'm surprised
talk about a relief Factor like when
he's when he does his sentence like oh
my God you know maybe wow baby's okay
subject and a predicate holy yes it is
like it's like what she's doing the
Secret Service is actually trying to
protect him from natural causes
that's funny thanks a lot that's good
that's good you know Emily uh cat's
right like he's 80 but he's not a strong
80. you know like Stuart Varney
and weighs me so much about the lips is
that
it's okay about the number right and
they say for example uh the chair of one
of the New Hampshire Democratic groups
straight up said and then a newspaper
printed this he said well Tom Brady won
a Super Bowl at age 43 so I think we
have to reassess aging what the hell
does that have to do with our president
being the Crypt Keeper nothing all that
they want to do is make the conversation
about the number to say well you know
now the Medical Science and miracles
happen that's not the point the point is
we all know a million 90 year olds that
are literally smarter than we are and
more with it and then 40 year olds that
act like they're 102. there's always an
example for each and the bottom line is
our president is absolutely mortifying
that Montage should have been that
should be the campaign video of the
Republican nominee over and over and
over
I still feel guilty about it don't feel
guilty I know I know what am I talking
about I have no soul Kaylee
um what do you think do you think that I
I still think you know what what if he
was 30 years actually younger he could
be more dangerous because then he'd have
more energy at least he's sleeping half
the day he was still saying the same
things 30 years ago I mean this is a guy
who's never been with it but the New
York Times you pick a copy up they say
that experts say Mr Biden and Mr Trump
are in the category of super agers
because they age better than their peers
said no one ever because Trump and Biden
are not in the same category I can tell
you because Biden carries around these
cheat sheets I used to make them for
Trump right I'd put covid graphs on
there really complicated things like you
know facts that you want to recall Biden
say you take your seat you stand up you
talk to the lady across the room I'm
surprised it doesn't say you go to the
bathroom now yeah um but Nancy you know
Nancy Pelosi she said we're in sending
this over to the next generation of
leadership talk to your buddy Joe Mann
we're ready for the next generation and
it ain't him that's right
in his in his defense I will say that
Biden has done one thing and no
president ever has what he fell up a
flight of stairs three times
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else